this is a PSA a public service
announcement stinky people what the [ __ ]
stinky people can I ask you something do
you know that you say I'm not sitting
this is a serious question do you know
that you smell like you [ __ ] yourself Bo
also known as body odor aka the reason
why people treat you like the Elephant
Man and you always wonder why people
avoided you your whole life well here's
the answer [ __ ] you see it isn't
because you're an [ __ ] nope it's
because you smell like an [ __ ] what
was it why won't we give you us because
the closer we get to your stanky ass the
closer we often pass it out and kill it
ourselves
the only reason for you to smell the way
you do is if you work out you had some
stranger's activity or you're homeless
you have a smell Bo so then you just
open your mouth a little bit
take a moment now today to go to the
store and buy something I'm not sure if
you heard this invention that came out
recently it's called soap [ __ ] this one
in the black and for those of you who
don't know is activated by something
called water the other is also your
friend don't fight it
and don't make excuses to why you don't
lose it somebody once told me that the
owner cost too much to buy and that's
the reason why he doesn't use it I was
gonna call 5 bucks [ __ ] I will
give you 5 dollars and a prayer if you
just use some deodorant do you realize
that you stay so much you are actively
killing out lausanne who every time you
walk by a tree all the leaves fall off
like [ __ ] ah here's the thing when
you shower you should be actively
washing yourself so on the face does not
get rid of the stench on the body bigger
people especially you got a lot of
surface area to work on when water comes
down this way [ __ ]
half the time is not gonna go all the
way to your big ass bag we all know with
us bigger people wanna wait at the face
and trickle down to our man breasts
honestly I want to tell you to go jump
off a bridge not to kill yourself but
the 48s to bathe but then again your
dirty ass will probably poison on one
supply last bit of advice brush your
teeth just do it I don't want to hear it
there is no reason for you
to brush your teeth Heiko walk around
looking like you replace your teeth with
a bag of Cheetos there are a million
toothpaste commercials and not one of
them scared you straight to brush your
teeth once you want to know what nobody
will talk to you because it's hard to
speak to you what we're holding our
breath that means we will rather
suffocate the breathe oxygen that should
tell you something if my PSA has
offended you in any way let me just say
this you must be the one that stinks go
wash your stank ass if later on tonight
I ask you to be my girlfriend right I'm
receiving a speeding ticket right now if
y'all can't tell see the [ __ ] behind
me yep how you gonna do this new man
just won't get back home it's all I
wanna do you'll get me spring ticking
yeah